in just a moment we'll present
Hollywood's top glamour event of the
year the 31st star-studded Academy
Awards presentations in a special
two-hour program then following at 12:30
a.m. East Standard Time see the Jack
Paar show over most of these NBC
stations
good evening mr. Halden good evening
John Wayne and I are here to welcome you
to the 31st annual Academy right for the
next two hours the biggest news of the
entertainment world is going to be made
right here over 500 reporters and
photographers gathered in this pavilion
alongside other works and pages theaters
are going to apply snippets of the next
two hours to nearly a million people
around the globe and now that we've
dazzled you with statistics of try to
dazzle you with the show it started at
four o'clock this morning
outside the pages theater now the
Hollywood elite
it's over Jim Tom Academy
picture arts and sciences are
mr. Lyon
now they got us opening this show I
didn't think they were even going to ask
us back it's the wrong spot in the wrong
show and they fooled us first cause it's
a strong show but they told us it's all
begin the stream so it's
they said we'd be just the thing here
and they said they turned out Frank and
Bing here Frank and big food obviously
missed
you can know how thrilled we both are to
be here uh proud to be part of this cat
but one thing is more than just
painfully clear they wanted us out of
here fast
why should we feel obligated let them
use the ones they nominated if you're
weighing Birds we went missed the bus
what we should do is cut it's all right
they say in the trade that we're great
in these role they must think they're
talking to door both know the part for
which we give our soul the parts with
the nicer
it was Grundy must be pleased how they
come a man who be emceeing for til next
year baby reiterate is great
the casual side look at you now forget
the tense and tight
well the best acting the gun bishop
they'll do too now
Oh
you
are you thank you very much good evening
ladies and gentlemen welcome to chance
of a lifetime
yes sir Ronald round she goes and where
she stops only price and Waterhouse
knows I want to tell you I hope you all
saved your ticket stubs because we're
awarding the Oscars by number tonight
that's not true but didn't feel good for
a minute huh I want to say this is the
big night of the year for Hollywood all
eyes of the world are focused on this
stage for some there will be glory and
applause for others heartbreak and tears
but enough about me I'm used to it I'm
getting to be known as the Pagliacci of
the teleprompter and I don't care about
an Oscar really I'd rather have friends
now for the first time I have a good
excuse for not being nominated this year
I haven't been well and I'm getting
sicker every minute I'm here tonight
against my doctor's orders he wanted my
tickets
now I wanted to do this show but they
want me to take things easy so I've
already lined up a job as wardrobe man
on the Brigitte Bardot picture the pay
isn't much for the fringe benefits of
terrific incidentally this Academy
Awards show tonight has the largest
viewing audience in history doesn't it
give you a wonderful warm feeling to
know that all over America millions of
people are sitting in front of their
television sets and saying what happened
at tales of Wells Fargo
and I do want to announce that the
awards may be held up for a few minutes
is a little trouble backstage price
caught water house with an eraser the
ladies in general we have a great show
tonight to give you an idea Ed Sullivan
is in our audience that is a glamorous
group the cloakroom is proud of mink and
chinchilla and Sables they have an armed
guard just to keep them from mating but
this is a great guide and Hollywood has
had a great year some of the pictures
were grim but what realism in fact I'm
surprised to see Susan Hayward here
tonight now they've seated all the
nominees on the aisle this year so they
can get to the stage quickly but
Hollywood has become jaded after so many
years of Academy Awards they're all just
sitting there calmly in their mink
stoles black tie and tracks track shoes
they look wonderful and you can feel the
tension in the air
this makes Cape Canaveral look like a
rest home yes this is the only show in
the world where the best acting is done
by the losers
the program tonight will have five five
master ceremonies five MCS what a waste
what would I be left to say after I
steal her idiot cards now I was selected
to open the show and I'm gonna be
followed by David Niven that is if the
balloons on time and after that we have
some amusing remarks by Mort Sahl
the favorite comedian of nuclear
physicists everywhere
mort's backstage putting pearl studs in
a sweater right now and incidentally
there's so many Englishmen on the show
this year backstage looks like the
fallout from The Late Late Show I've put
a dime in the Coke machine back there
and a tea bag came out we have Sir
Laurence Olivier David Niven Peter
Ustinov Sir Alec Guinness Sir Alec
Guinness imagine knighting a comedian
I'll civilize can you get the closest I
ever came to being knighted over here
was one day when I tapped me with a
putter
said that's my ball
sir Lauren should feel right at home
here tonight because after the show the
losers gathered in the parking lot and
do the last scene from Hamlet
we have some wonderful new talent the
show in Hollywood's always encourage new
talent and this year we have such new
faces as Russ Tamblyn Dean Jones ricky
nelson maurice chevalier is matt
Chevalier great he's been smiling for 70
years course you'd smile too if you put
champagne on your Wheaties
I said you'd smile too if you put
champagne on your Wheaties
sorry okay and this was a big year for
the girl Shirley Lane Shirley MacLaine
was nominated for playing a lady of easy
virtue Elizabeth Taylor played a
frustrated cat Deborah Carr played a
neurotic who learned about sex and Roz
Russell played a screwball spinster and
Susan Hayward played a narcotic addict
who went to the gas chamber put them all
together they spell mother
and I understand that next year the
Academy is giving an Oscar for the best
old movie on The Late Late Show with the
old movies on TV it's enough to make a
new Roddick out of any actor you see
yourself as you were then and as you are
now and you want to tear your hair out
only it's too late I not only have to
worry about my future on channel 4 I
have to face my past on channel 13 and
they show those pictures over and over
King Kong has been on TV so often the
gorillas now doing the commercials and
the way they cut those pictures I saw an
old road picture last night and Bing and
I aren't even in it it was the road to
morocco starring dr. shows footpads vic
tanning a supporting cast of 45 products
you remember the plot Bing and I are
chasing Dorothy Lamour ovale at the end
of the picture chef Milani gets hurt and
the week before I saw a Humphrey Bogart
and Katharine Hepburn dragging the
African Queen through 14 miles of
Campbell's chicken soup
they had a heck of a time the paddle
wheel kept getting stuck in the noodles
and now before we go to the awards
ladies and gentlemen will now pause for
10 seconds while Diane barsy turns off
her television set
ladies and gentlemen it's my great
pleasure now to introduce one of
Hollywood's finest producer directors of
president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences mr. George
Stevens right here
thank you for the governors of the
Academy I'd like to welcome you all to
this the second of our awards
presentations to be televised as a
public service you are the guests of the
motion picture industry the artists
creators producers distributors and your
neighbors who operate the motion picture
theaters of America now to get the
business at hand I'd like to introduce
you to mr. Bill Miller of Price
Waterhouse & Company the guardian of
Oscars secrets the ballots are here they
have been counted and only mr. melih
knows or what they say thank you Bill
stand ready the motion picture industry
thanks you for being with us and you
hope you enjoy the evening
you